resolvamos primero un par de problemas
convirtiendo fracciones a porcentajes y
después convirtiendo los porcentajes a
fracciones ok después podremos hacer
algunos problemas denunciados digamos
entonces vamos a resolver nuestro primer
problema en práctica vamos a convertir
524 abós a un porcentaje y esta es la
forma que me gusta hacerlo prefiero
convertir primero a decimales y ya que
lo tienes en decimales es directísimo
convertirlo a un porcentaje entonces la
manera de convertir a decimales es
dividir el este número es decir poner 5
literalmente es un 5 entre 24 verdad es
decir 24 cabe cuántas veces en 5 y vamos
a tener que añadir algunos espacios con
con este con ceros porque 24 es un
número mucho más grande que 5 verdad
entonces pongamos nuestro número decimal
aquí y ahora si podemos hacer la
división 24 caben 50 veces verdad
entonces 0 por 24 es cero
y hacemos la resta 50 es 5 y bajamos
este 0 directamente hasta acá ahora sí
24 cuántas veces cabe en 50 y cabe dos
veces verdad 2 por 42 x
2448 verdad dos por cuatro es 8 y 2 por
2 son 4 y ahora restamos 50 menos 48 es
2 y bajamos otro 0 bajamos otro 0 y
vamos a continuar bajando ceros verdad
hasta que no tengamos recibo aquí baje
este 0 y 24 cabe en 2002 es verdad 0 por
24 es cero
hacemos la resta y nos da 20 bajemos
otro 0 vamos a bajar otro 0 aquí muy
bien y ahora 24 caben 200 digamos que
serán unas ocho veces tal vez
como ocho veces
serán nueve
serían ocho veces verdad vamos a ver si
8 funciona y ahora 4 en realidad hacer
divisiones es como todo un arte verdad
ahora 4 x 8 32 llevamos 32 x 8 16 y 3
son 19 verdad entonces fue correcto
fueron 8 veces ahora 200 menos 192
simplemente son 8 verdad y bajamos otro
vamos a bajar otro cero aquí 24 cabe en
80 unas tres veces no puede ser cuatro
porque dos por cuatro es ocho y cuatro
por cuatro
le sumarían no entonces 3 por 24 son 72
y 80 menos 72 son 8 y bajamos otro 0 y
entonces tenemos como aquí tenemos una
reserva infinita de ceros podemos bajar
otro 0 y otra vez 24 caben 80 tres veces
verdad y va a repetirse una y otra y
otra vez
así que 5 entre 24 que quiero que
entiendas por qué sucede esto cada vez
que hagamos esto vamos a obtener un 3 y
baja un 72 restamos y obtenemos 8 y
entonces vamos a tener una cadena
infinita aquí de números 3 verdad así
que esto simplemente será
0.20 8 3 y el 3 se repite verdad ahora
si queremos escribir esto en forma de
porcentaje que la palabra porcentaje
dice por ciento déjenme separarlo esto
es por ciento verdad siento viene de la
palabra 100 y esto es por ciento por
ciento así que qué es esto es esto es
0.20 y cómo es esto en cien en
porcentaje a lo mejor esto puede
confundirte o quizás no por una forma en
que puedes hacer esto es lo mismo que
podrías hacerlo digamos de esta manera
este decimal 0.20 8 y 3 repitiéndose es
lo mismo es lo mismo que
20.83 y el 3 repitiéndose sobre 100 ok
esto es cuántos tenemos por cada 100
verdad o puedes decir que esto es igual
a 20.83 entre 100 o bien
20.83 periódico por ciento verdad esto
todo esto es equivalente una manera muy
rápida de pensar cómo pasar de decimales
a porcentajes que puedes multiplicar por
100 y después poner el signo de
porcentaje o si vas hacia atrás divides
entre 100 ok y con eso y quitamos el
signo de porcentaje verdad ahora
convirtamos un porcentaje en 1
y lo voy a hacer en azul entonces
digamos que tenemos el 16 por ciento
recuerda que esto significa 16 por cada
100 verdad entonces esto es lo mismo que
16 sobre 100 por ejemplo centavo no
centavo es una centésima parte de un de
un dólar o de un peso de lo que tú
quieras pero bueno vamos a simplificar
esto dividimos entre 4 y acá arriba nos
da 4 y 100 entre 4 es 25 y ese fue un
calentamiento ahora hagamos algunos
problemas reales ahora sí
nos dicen una televisión tiene descuento
y tiene el 35% de descuento y tiene un
nuevo precio de de 195 dólares cuál era
el precio antes del descuento entonces
si x es el precio
antes del descuento
cuando quitas el
35% de eso es como que tienes ahí es
cuando resulta que tiene 195 dólares es
decir x menos punto 35 que es el 35%
ok tengo mi precio antes del descuento y
le quito el 35% de ese mismo precio nos
debe dar 195 dólares eso es lo que me
está diciendo esencialmente ahora
resolvemos para x y esto lo puedes ver
como un x menos 0.35 de x ok y eso será
0.65
x verdad correcto y si sumas 0.65 punto
35 nos va a dar igual a una equis verdad
y esto debe ser igual a
195 dólares y ahora puedes dividir ambos
lados de esta ecuación por
0.65 de hecho me gusta más hacerlo como
fracción déjenme ponerlo de esta forma
esto es 65 sobre 100 por x
y esto es igual a
195 ahora podemos multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por la inversa de
hecho es podríamos incluso hasta
simplificar la fracción dividir el
numerador y el denominador por 5 y
entonces nos queda 13 sobre 20 verdad
esto es 13 sobre 20 por x que es igual a
195 ahora podemos multiplicar ambos
lados por la inversa de esta fracción
que es 20 sobre 13 verdad
entonces multiplicamos también del lado
derecho de este lado esto se cancela en
verdad y entonces nos queda que x es
igual a 195 por 20 sobre 13 y lo cual
podríamos averiguar pero vamos a sacar
la calculadora
195 por 20 sobre
/ / 13 nos da 300 ok entonces esto es
igual a
300 300 dólares entonces
195 dólares ya habiéndole quitado el
descuento quiere decir que el precio
original era de 300 dólares verdad
quitamos el 35% de 300 dólares lo cual
es 105 dólares y con eso te quedarías
con 195 así que 300 es nuestro precio
original hagamos otro a una empleada en
una tienda le pagan actualmente
950 dólares por hora
si ella trabaja todo el año obtiene el
12% de incremento en su salario
cuál será su nueva tarifa por ahora
después del incremento ahorita ella gana
950 dólares si trabaja por 12 años
entonces perdón si ella trabaja todo el
año le pagarán 12 por ciento más de lo
que le pagan ahora es decir 12 por
ciento de 950 su nueva tarifa sería todo
esto verdad entonces esto es lo mismo
que 9.50 más
0.12 que es el 12% y que multiplica a
950 verdad esto es lo mismo que 1 por
950 más 0.12 de 950 y esto es lo mismo
que 1.12 que multiplica a 950 verdad es
este 1 y este punto 12 nos da 1.2 de
verdad sólo estoy sumando eso porque
está multiplicando a lo mismo que es
9.50 entonces estamos creciendo el 12%
verdad entonces
1.12 por 950 va a ser igual a nuestro
nuevo número a la nueva al nuevo sueldo
que le van a dar entonces déjenme
multiplicar esto
9.50 por
1.2
aunque hay dos por cero es 0 2 por 5 es
10 llevamos 12 por 9 18 y 1 que
llevábamos son 19 y pondré un cero aquí
muy bien uno por cero es 0 1 por 55 y 1
por 99 ponemos ahora 20 es verdad y uno
por cero es 0 1 por 55 y 1 por 99 y
ahora podemos sumar
muy bien ahora estos dos ceros dan 0
estos ceros también dan 0 9 y 5 es 14 y
llevamos
11 y 1 son 2 y 9 son 11 + 5 son 16 y
llevamos 1 y 1 y 19 son 10 verdad y
ahora contamos el número de decimales
aquí hay dos y acá abajo son otros dos
en total tenemos cuatro que es lo que
hay que recordar recorrer perdón hacia
la izquierda entonces aquí nos queda el
número decimal su nuevo salario será de
10 puntos 64 dólares por ahora
10.64 no tienes que escribir esos ceros
ahí verdad porque son ceros a la derecha
así que este es un nuevo salario por
hora después del incremento muy bien
hagamos uno más uno más la tienda y la
tienda ve venden bicicletas ambas
compran bicis del mismo proveedor al
mismo precio la tienda tiene un 40% de
aumento
ok eso significa que independientemente
de lo que pagaron van a tener eso a un
precio 40% más alto mientras que la
tienda ve tiene un 250 por ciento de
aumento la tienda ve tiene una oferta
permanente siempre venden al 60 por
ciento de esos precios
cuál tienda tiene el mejor beneficio
digamos que ambos están comprando las
bicicletas entonces digamos que x va a
ser igual al precio del proveedor ese es
el precio al que las dos tiendas de
bicis compran sus bicicletas ambas
compran bicis del mismo proveedor al
mismo precio eso es esta equis con la
que voy a empezar correcto ahora hagamos
el escenario de la tienda
qué a qué precio vende la tienda ellos
venden la bici x más el 40% de equis
verdad 0.40 de x lo cual es igual a 1.4
de x eso es por cuánto vende una
bicicleta a la tienda ahora la tienda
vez un poquito más interesante porque
ellos tienen un aumento de 250 por
ciento
bueno ellos dicen que venden su
bicicleta a x más
250 que es 2.5 por x un 100 por ciento
de aumento implicaría literalmente sumar
otra x esto es 250 por ciento y como
dijimos sólo puedes dividir por 100 y
obtienes 2.5 verdad entonces ellos
venden x más 2.5 de x lo cual es igual a
3.5 de x eso es como el precio de la
nueva bici pero entonces van a vender
esta bici al 60 por ciento verdad perdón
le van a quitar el 60 por ciento de
descuento entonces realmente tenemos
punto 5 x qué es lo que a lo que venden
esa bici y le van a quitar el 60 por
ciento de ese precio que es menos 0.6 de
ese precio pero ese precio es 3.5 de
equis verdad y podríamos ver esto como 1
por 3.5 de x menos 0.6 por 3.5 de x que
es uno menos 0.6
ok por
3.5 de x y 1 menos 0.6 será
0.4
0.4 si le quita 60 por ciento es lo
equivalente a venderla al 40% del precio
al que ya lo estaban dando verdad
probablemente podrás decir el 60 por
ciento menos
es lo mismo que vender al 0.4 por ciento
perdón al 0.4 del precio o el 40% verdad
ahora si tomamos 3.5 x 0.4 obtenemos 5 x
4 es 20 llevamos 2 3 x 4 son 12 y llevo
2 son 14 muy bien y ahora tenemos
22 números a la derecha del signo del
punto decimal perdón así que nos da 1.4
entonces van a venderla a 1.4 de x
entonces en cualquier tienda de hecho
vas a pagar el mismo precio digamos que
venden las bicicletas del proveedor a
100 dólares entonces en la tienda vas a
pagar 140 y en la tienda también vas a
pagar 140 pero en la tienda de piensas
que obtienes un descuento